früher hatte man sparen das geld so zur
bank zu tragen ich mache das jetzt heute
um einfach aber und sind allen
mittlerweile klar wer spart verliert die
niedrigzins politik der ezb sorgt dafür
dass wir nicht mehr sechs oder sieben
prozent zinsen bekommen sondern im
allerbesten fall 0,5 prozent wenn sie
jetzt sagen ich lege euro pro monat zur
seite oder ich habe einmal 10.000 euro
was ist das in 40 jahren wird sie können
sich davon in 40 jahren nur die hälfte
dessen kaufen wenn da 17 5 prozent
inflation abgeben man bekommt aktuell
keine zinsen und durch corona wird sich
das auch nicht so schnell ändern das
heißt wir können aktuell oder zumindest
fühlt es sich so an als könnten wir
nicht mehr so sparen wir unsere eltern
oder großeltern in immobilien zu
investieren ist in der stadt jetzt auch
nicht wirklich drin
gerade als berufseinsteiger wir müssen
uns aber privat um unsere altersvorsorge
kümmern
die frage ist nur wie der größte fehler
ist zu warten als meiner sicht ist der
größte fehler ist auf die lange bank zu
schieben erwischt bin ich dann jetzt
schon zu spät dran
nein auf keinen fall also im gegenteil
ich sage lieber keine fehler machen
erstmal ja und genau darum geht es in
dieser folge sahen wir sind alle gut
darin das sind bisschen auf die lange
bank zu schieben und machen dadurch
wahrscheinlich schon den ersten fehler
eine sache kann ich euch vorab schon
verraten es ist gar nicht so schlimm wie
man denkt
das thema altersvorsorge ist immer super
weit weg und sehr abstrakt deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht gucken wir uns das ganze
einfach mal an meinem fall an
ich arbeite jetzt seit drei jahren bin
ich im berufsleben und fertig mit meinem
master ich bin 30 jahre alt ich wohl
noch hier in meiner schönen wg ich habe
keine kinder ich habe auch noch keinen
riester vertrag ich habe aktuell kein
sparplan keine betriebliche
altersvorsorge keine lebensversicherung
und hatte bevor ich mich anfang an mit
dem thema auseinanderzusetzen auch
ziemlich wenig ahnung ist macht
wahrscheinlich den meisten nicht
besonders viel spaß aber informiert zu
sein über das thema ist wahnsinnig
wichtig gerade als frau bin nicht
informiert sein heißt es ist euer wir
haben ganz viele verbraucher die kommen
dann erst zehn jahre nach beruf starb
die haben an der uni schon am campus
sind sie angesprochen worden bei irgend
ein bewerbertraining von dem
finanzvertrieb
und die haben dann schon drei
rentenversicherung eine riester policen
der private rentenversicherung eine
police und man stellt dann die bilanz
feste stelle fast überall nur verluste
ja warum nicht weil die kapitalmärkte
schlecht gelaufen sind sondern weil die
produkte schlecht waren also teilweise
war es einfach unsinnige anlage
strategien und teilweise waren es auch
einfach sind die ganzen kosten für
vertrieb und versicherung so das heißt
erst mal wenn man den fehler nicht
gemacht hatte schon mal gut das heißt
man braucht diese ganzen komplizierten
produkte nicht zumindest nicht zum staat
und das macht die sache um einiges
leichter eine säule der altersvorsorge
ist die gesetzliche rentenversicherung
2009 10 habe ich zum ersten mal das hier
bekommen dass der rentenbescheid der
gesetzlichen über sich herum und wenn
man jetzt im durchschnitt der letzten
fünf kalenderjahren nimmt so wird das
hier ja mal berechnet dann lande ich bei
grandiosen 687 euro und zwar zu beim
renteneintritt datum am 31
2057 problem ist tatsächlich der
gesetzgeber verlangt von jedem
verbraucher von jedem bürger soll privat
vorsorgen und das ärgerliche was wir
auch seit vielen jahren schon
kritisieren ist er hat letztendlich sagt
er den leuten hier ihr müsst abschließen
im grunde ist das nachbarn
haifischbecken weil alle
möglichen haifische da unterwegs sind
ich nehme das beispiel weil es so
plastisch ist die im grunde das beste
wollen von den anlegern nämlich das geld
die guten günstigen produkte die wir
landen gar nicht auf den konten der
verbraucher die schließt keine ab was
würden sie sich denn aus
verbraucherschutz nicht politisch
wünschen wenn der verbraucher einfach so
wie bei der gesetzlichen rente hatte ja
auch nicht die wahl zwischen 20
gesetzlichen rentenversicherungsträgern
sondern da ist es ein anbieter und da
ist unsere forderung kapital ist nicht
kompliziert weltweit kostengünstig
anlegen dieses prinzip ist sehr gut
belegt auch in der wissenschaftlichen
forschung und dann ist es ein
standardprodukt und in der politischen
diskussion ist das standardprodukt auch
seit einigen jahren das wird noch nicht
umgesetzt weil natürlich das nicht im
interesse der gesamten finanz lobby ist
aber wir kommen auf kurz oder lang nicht
drum herum wenn wir können uns das gar
nicht leisten da jedes jahr zwei prozent
provisionen und kosten an die
finanzlobby abzudrücken
aber es geht um die altersvorsorge der
bürger und der zins 0
das heißt wir brauchen irgendwann auch
ein stativ standardprodukt in schweden
wird das beispielsweise so geregelt
solange es hier aber anders ist muss man
sich selbst informieren
ich fühle mich irgendwie schlecht
informiert und ihre studie sagt auch das
geht jetzt nicht nur mir so und gibt
studien die zeigen dass frauen
wesentlich geringere finanzmarkt
kenntnisse haben als männer und wir
haben im letzten jahr eine umfrage unter
knapp 1600 deutschen gemacht
repräsentativ um herauszufinden wie
steht es denn mit der altersvorsorge
planungen und auch da haben frauen
wesentlich häufiger als männer gesagt
ich weiß das thema ist wichtig aber ich
fühle mich wahnsinnig unsicher und ich
weiß einfach nicht was ich machen soll
das ist ein riesiges problem und zwar
für alle geschlechter aber online gibt
es wirklich auch gute infos und wer sich
ein bisschen informiert kann nicht so
viel falsch machen und ein erster
schritt könnte ein gespräch bei der
verbraucherzentrale sein was ist denn
das wichtig weil wenn ich jetzt sage ich
starte bei 0 und muss mich jetzt und
will mich altersvorsorge für meine
altersvorsorge ist nichts anderes als
erstmal vermögen aufzubauen
ja wenn man aber schulden hat
da haben ist das gegenteil von vermögen
aufbauen so dass heißt erstmal möglichst
ein polster schaffen so faustdick ist
ein paar monatsgehälter zur seite legen
die einfach auch wenn es keine zinsen
bringt nur sicher anlegen schon zwei ist
wenn man möchte kann man sich auch hier
und da noch ein versicherungsschutz
einkaufen wenn man berufsunfähig wird
oder ins ausland reisen möchte und dann
kann man so langsam überlegen wie kann
man langfristig spaß
es gibt natürlich auch ganz viele
menschen die können einfach nicht zurück
liegen werden nur den mindestlohn
verdient der kann ich einfach im monat
noch viel zurücklegen weil man muss ja
auch was essen und die miete bezahlen
ist ein riesiges thema aber für ganz
woanders hier geht es einfach darum was
machen menschen die job haben und die
möglichkeit haben ein bisschen was
zurückzulegen von dem was die verdienen
ich jetzt erst mal nachfragen wohin soll
die reise gehen ist es ist es gewünscht
oder ein ziel in den nächsten jahren
auch irgendwann immobilieneigentum zu
erwerben wenn es dann keine option ist
dann kann man natürlich über
verschiedene anlageklassen sprechen dann
ist wichtig risiken streuen und uns die
frage welche risikobereitschaft kann man
denn eingehen was das albert
schwankungen drin dann ist mir darüber
sprechen wenn immobilien er an anvisiert
werden und man tatsächlich das als ziel
auch anstrebt und dann ist unser rat er
ja möglicherweise nicht zu viel risiko
eingehen weil an den märkten wenn man
das denn riskant angelegt kann man zwar
mehr zinsen und mehrerträge kriegen aber
es ist halt auch immer das risiko dass
das geld weniger wert wird und dann
platzt vielleicht der traum vom
eigenheim zusammengefasst muss man sich
fragen
bin ich schuldenfrei kenne ich meine ein
und ausgaben habe ich ein geldpolster
für dinge wie eine waschmaschine oder
eine autoreparatur und willig absehbar
mieterin bleiben wenn ihr alle diese
fragen mit ja beantworten könnt könnt
ihr damit anfangen euch mit dem
langfristigen anlegen
auseinanderzusetzen ich hab so ein
bisschen mehr eine ahnung davon was ich
vielleicht tun könnte und bei mir
altersvorsorge zu machen also ein
vermögen aufzubauen
jetzt stellt sich für mich immer noch
die frage wie fange ich denn jetzt ganz
genau damit an
da hab ich mir jetzt noch mal jemanden
zu hilfe geholt mit dem ich jetzt gleich
sprechen kann das ist sein die von
finanz tipp jetzt machst du das was wir
sehr stark profitieren nämlich du musst
dich mit dem thema aktien
auseinandersetzen aktien gefährlich und
so weiter aber das ist tatsächlich so
dass wir sagen langfristig kommt man um
das thema aktien nicht drum herum warum
weil alle anderen alternativen die
irgendwas mit zinsen zu tun haben so gut
wie nichts mehr abwerfen
das problem ist nämlich der deutschen
lieben diese geschichte mit dem sparen
seit jahren schrumpfen aber die zinsen
sind die inflation aber bleibt das heißt
das geld wird weniger wert die
aktienmärkte kennen langfristigen
vergleich noch eine richtung nämlich
nach oben
wer langfristig in den dax investiert
hat bekam zum beispiel im durchschnitt
etwa acht prozent rendite
was wir empfehlen ist sozusagen jetzt
nicht dax deutsche aktien zu nehmen
sondern ganz breit weltweit und zwar in
form eines etf das berühmte wort etf
exchange traded fund ist nix anderes
wenn jetzt mal den dax nehmen statt der
vorgang ist die 30 aktien im dax
enthalten sind und pax die zusammen ein
fonds und dieser fonds enthält dann
einfach diese 30 dax-aktien macht genau
das gleiche wieder dax das wäre dann ein
etf auf den dax
bloß dass man eben nicht den dax nehmen
sollte weil nur deutschland ist ein
bisschen risikoreich und nur 30 aktien
ist tatsächlich auch zu wenig sondern
man sollte das ganz breit streuen zb ein
beispiel wäre weltweite aktienindex msc
world er enthält 1.600 aktien was ist so
meine infrastruktur als erstes brauchst
du ein wertpapierdepot ein gutes
wertpapierdepot am besten ein
kostenloses das kann bei der eigenen
bank seien ja da muss man halt schauen
was diese für
für konditionen anbieten aber es gibt da
sehr gute angebote im internet
solange das der bank ist die in
deutschland ansässig ist kann ich da
auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel falsch
machen ich sollte mich halt gut
informieren welche gebühren die haben ja
und sie sollten auch vor allen dingen
gute sparplan gute sparplan angebote für
etf sind besondere anbieten man suchen
sich ein etf der diesen index
nachzeichnet also dann im grunde 3000
aktien kauft kostet vielleicht 0,2
prozent gebühren pro jahr oder kaufen
sie diesen vor sparplan
dazu braucht man auch keinen berater
mehr da muss man muss sich nur die
direktbank aussuchen und die haben diese
fonds allem angebot und dann kauft man
das wenn man noch ein anlageberater bei
der bank fragt da wird man keinen etf
empfohlen kriegen da wird es dann mal
rentenversicherung sein warum bei da2
3000 euro provision winken wenn ich
jetzt mit 30 starter habe ich schon viel
verpasst bin ich schon bin ich viel aber
jedes jahr zählt weil der größte vorteil
den du auch mit mit 30 hast ist die zeit
die zeitarbeit für dich das was ich
vorhin schon mal kurz angedeutet habe so
ganz gut je nachdem wie es läuft aber
für die kenner erwarten fünf prozent
rendite unterstellen würde was nicht
unrealistisch ist ja so dann kostet ein
jedes jahr wenn man sagt ich leg 200
jeden euro jeden monat zur zurück dann
kommen da am ende irgendwas zwischen 10
und 12 tausend euro weniger raus also
ganz grob gesagt so ein tausender im
monat jeden monat den ich warte kostet
mich in die endabrechnungen tausender
und nicht weil ich weniger eingezahlt
hat sondern weil weniger rendite weniger
zinseszinseffekt über die zeit zustande
gekommen ist
es macht manchmal sogar spaß aber nicht
jetzt anguckt wie viel geld kann man
wann wie mit welcher in vitro anlegen
und was kann dabei herauskommen weil
dieser zinseszinseffekt ist einfach
möglich nicht zu vernachlässigen was die
zukunft bringt wissen wir natürlich alle
nicht aber die daten sind
sag ich mal aus 100 jahren relativ
konstant aktienmarkt rentiert etwa 4
prozentpunkte besser als der zinsmarkt
warum sollte dass die nächsten 100 jahre
so ganz anders sein wenn ich jetzt er
überlege es gibt hier trotzdem haben
restrisiko das ist ja trotzdem irgendwie
geld ist klar sie halt angebunden an
weltweit natürlich sehr viele
unternehmen aber ein risiko bleibt
konkret noch mal zwei sachen erstens
muss die bereitschaft mitbringen zu
wissen mein geld wird bei solchen
anlagen immer schwanken und zwar gehörig
nasir krone verrauscht das zeug halt auf
einmal ganz groß in ordnung 30 prozent
marke die tiefe das heißt man muss die
bereitschaft mitbringen
diese doch ziemlichen schwankungen an
der börse einfach auszusitzen und dann
ist noch die andere frage
wenn du dir sagst du hast 10.000 euro
das natürlich noch überlegen was brauche
ich denn sonst noch weil jeder euro der
da rein muss muss ich mir bewusst sein
sollte mindestens 15 jahre oder für die
alte sorge 30 jahre plus da drin
die diverse kaputt geht muss man sich
wahrscheinlich auch über ganz viele
andere dinge gesprochen also über den
schlimmsten fall dass dieses geld auch
langfristig irgendwie den bach
runtergeht dass man langfristig damit
massive verluste hat dieses szenario
will ich mir nicht ausmalen einzelnen
firmen wird es da immer mal schlecht
gehen das sind 1600 und ns däne in der
masse über einen langen zeitraum
wirklich einen langen zeitraum schlecht
geht das ist das ende unserer
weltwirtschaft das ende unseres
lebensstils dann drehen wir darüber dass
wahrscheinlich investitionen dem
bauernhof besser gewesen wäre mir wurde
jetzt tatsächlich so ein bisschen die
angst genommen vor diesem thema
altersvorsorge weil ich einfach das
gefühl es muss nicht ultra kompliziert
sein und das richtig dass erstmal sich
zu informieren und dann auch zu starten
man kann es nicht oft genug und
eindringlich sagen gerade für die frauen
weil er so viele faktoren eine rolle
spielen die magere kenneth i viele
frauen scheinen auch noch nicht so
bewusst zu sein auch dass das
unterhaltsrecht reformiert ist also sich
auf den mann zu verlassen ist auch
wirklich gar keine gute idee
warum ist es für junge frauen gerade
besonders wichtig ein schlagwort war
sicherlich allen bekannt ist der
sogenannte gender pay gap also frauen
verdienen weniger und der übersetzt sich
eben
dann auch in einen sogenannten gender
pay gap also auch wenn man in rente geht
hat man als frau typischerweise weniger
rentenansprüche erworben als ein mann in
ihrer studie kam zum beispiel auch dass
frauen allein bei der gesetzlichen
rentenversicherung im alter 26 prozent
weniger rente bekommen als männer nur
auf die gesetzliche genau dann gibt es
noch unterschiede in der betrieblichen
rente das habe ich nicht selbst
untersucht aber wenn man das noch mit
dazu nimmt da gibt es auch
untersuchungen zu dann kommt man und die
private als dritte säule dann kommt man
auf ein eps von bis zu 50 prozent der
fehler ist immer der egal ob verheiratet
oder nicht verheiratet das sagen was wie
es ist ja weil es halt doch in
deutschland meist noch so ist es die
frau mehr zu hause bleibt wenn kinder da
sind wir uns nichts vormachen
trotz aller emanzipation dass immer der
fehler ist dass er für sie nicht mit
sport
damit komme ich nämlich auf jeden fall
nicht hin und das hier ist auch keine
wirkliche option immobilien fallen für
mich im moment raus
ja es ist aktuell einfach die beste
möglichkeit sein geld am kapitalmarkt
anzulegen wenn man lange zeit hat und
wenn man nicht direkt an das geld ran
muss und da muss ich mich jetzt einfach
noch mal für meinen fall ganz genau
schlau machen und dann einfach loslegen
und ich glaube das ist wirklich das
wichtigste
informiert euch und legt los aber das
wichtigste ist die info und wenn ihr
schon viele verträge habt schaut mal
vielleicht kriegt ihr auch ein termin
bei einer verbraucherzentrale und könnt
euch da einfach beraten lassen so dass
ihr gucken könnt was sind eure aktuellen
verträge wie viel zahlt ihr an gebühren
und lässt sich da vielleicht auch was
optimieren
[Musik]